what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
one two three what's going on guys this
is Rob and I'm gonna be dangerous here
and I am going to suggest a movie idea
for event for phase four and that movie
idea is Excalibur now I imagine a lot of
people are just kind of like who or what
is Excalibur assuming anybody even care
enough to watch this video at all
Excalibur is an interesting situation
depending on how the story goes it could
be really really cool or it could be
really boring but the notion behind it
is actually really awesome so back in
we're really back in the 1960s MRO first
sort of blowing up we know it's Stanley
Jack Kirby and you know Steve Ditko
pretty spider-man all those different
characters bringing Captain America back
Marvel Comics was largely in American
publication meaning that almost all the
superheroes pretty much all the
superheroes were based out of America
with the exception of a handful uncanny
x-men changed out a little bit and then
you had pretty much all the stories
being published in America and so the
result was that in 1976 Marvel broke out
of that and they launched an imprint
called Marvel UK I'm pretty sure it was
in 1976 and they launched Marvel UK and
their inaugural public really inaugural
title was Captain Britain comics number
one now Captain Britain is the first
real British character to get his own
solo series there were Marvel reprints
they were being published in Britain but
in terms of having like an actual wholly
owned British title or I guess really
you know a British character that was
Captain Britain and the cool thing about
this is that Brian Braddock was a guy
who was met with like God man like I'm I
really need to stop doing these things
off top my head
Brian Braddock was a guy I want to say
he was involved in a car wreck er there
was something that had gone on and I
want to say was a villain or someone who
had stepped in and messed with him but
then he was met by Merlin and he was
given a choice between the amulet of
might or I'm sorry the amulet of right
or the sword of might and he chose the
amulet of right which gives him super
strength speed durability I think he can
travel it like supersonic speeds or
something like that um but basically he
was like Britain's very own superhero
and it was pretty popular for a while
you saw some really cool stories too
like I always say the crooked world
story the story of madam Jasper's one of
my favorite stories and the Captain
Britain
comics it was amazing but Captain
Britain also has some pretty significant
foes like his brother Jimmy Braddock in
like warp reality on a universal scale
I'm pretty sure it's Universal but he's
a reality war four he's really really
powerful like he's he's a he's pretty
strong
he's pretty powerful but uh but
nonetheless the whole idea of Excalibur
is rooted in Marvel's Marvel's efforts
to take popular characters and blend
them with unpopular characters and a
title they couldn't really sell and the
reason why was because with Captain
Britain being as popular as he was he
wasn't that popular I mean he was
popular among readers in Britain but in
the United States a lot of people didn't
really care about him because they
really couldn't identify with him it
didn't really resonate with him and so
the results of this is that in 1984
Marvel launched a story called fall of
the mutants and fall the mutants is
actually kind of cool a cross don't run
didn't really cross over but it dealt
with the uncanny uncanny x-men it dealt
with x-factor and a dealt with the New
Mutants which were Marvel's three x-men
titles at the time and what you had is
you basically had three separate stories
that didn't really cross over or
intertwine instead it is kind of shared
a theme and the idea was basically the
mutants were dangerous and so on and so
forth but the the part that pertains to
us is the uncanny x-men part and the
reason why was that while you had
Captain Britain and you had him over
there doing his whole thing and he had
his girlfriend Megan who could
shape-shift and all that kind of stuff
the uncanny x-men were Marvel's like top
top comic I mean that was Marvel's comic
book the uncanny x-men were right up
there at the top I want to say that at
their peak DC's Teen Titans actually
outsold the uncanny x-men but like
between those two publications like
Marvel and DC had the comic book
industry on lockdown it was it was crazy
you know from the mid-1970s running up
into the mid 1980s you couldn't you
couldn't get a hold on on Marvel in DC I
mean there was them and then everybody
else like that's all there was to it
um valiant almost came close in the
early 1990s but you know then all that
stuff happened but the fact remains here
when it comes to the Excalibur team the
original roster was Captain Britain
Rachel summers Kitty Pryde and
Nightcrawler maybe Megan anyway the
whole basis behind this was that in the
fall of mutants storyline you
essentially had this this crazy villain
called the adversity
which is really really weird oh lord
have mercy it was it was weird so what
happened in this story is it dealt a lot
with a character of forge and forge is a
mutant who is like Tony Stark but the
difference is that his abilities is his
ability to like know how things work is
his mutant power like like Tony Stark is
just that damn smart that's how it is
when it comes to his character in Marvel
Comics he's just that good
forge is as good as Tony Stark the
reason why or I don't know it kind of
depends Tony Stark's never made a time
machine but forges made a time machine I
don't know who cares anyway the point is
is that if you were to have someone who
shut off forges mutant powers he'd be no
more capable of doing any of the stuff
that Tony Stark can do then like the
average you're walking down the street
who's like a history teacher like they'd
have he'd have no clue how to do any of
the stuff that star can do and he knows
about you know he knows how to do the
kind of things that star can do because
his mutant power is to reverse-engineer
technology to look at it and to know how
it works but the idea is that Forge is
also a shaman for the Cheyenne people
and so what had happened was that in his
early days as a kid he basically been
trained to be a shaman to basically be
someone who would be like their
spiritual leader for the Cheyenne
community it doesn't mean that he would
be sitting on a Native American
reservation all the time but it meant
that if they called on him for his aid
then he would respond to his people
before anything else ultimately Ford
rebuked that whole idea and forged
basically join the army and ended up you
know becoming like the the assistant to
the mutants or to the x-men actually a
member of the x-men that we know and
actually went on to form this happened
after the fall of mutants but he
actually went on to become the liaison
the government liaison between the
federal government and the x-factor team
are the first expert I'm sorry thus the
second x-factor team the first x-factor
team that was Cameron Hodge yeah Cameron
Hodge led Jean Grey Ice Man Warren
Worthington Cyclops and Angel um yeah
and that was Cameron Hodge and then you
then you had the whole like extinction
agenda where he was like screw you guys
you know and then decided to dick him
all over but it was it was extinction
agenda was kind of cool but in any event
the fact remains here one dedup
happening is there was the there was
this foe that the cheyenne people had
always been dealing with called the
adversary and it was a way to kind of
bring out like the whole cultural aspect
of native american history and it was
really really cool for what it was but
the the adversary was basically like
this demon and
and in Marvel Comics you have a lot of
those like there's a lot of demon
entities I mean you've got like the
cosmic entities and you've got like
Mephisto who's basically the devil he's
the one that makes people ghost writers
you have this you've got hella you've
got mistress dad do you have a lot of
those things on earth and the very early
days of Earth and Marvel Comics you had
the primal gods basically like these
ancient deities what actually ended up
happening is they basically went crazy
sort of sort of like killing and eating
each other devouring their powers and
then Gaia who is the sentience of earth
basically mother earth called in the she
called in like the God of all the gods
basically from Earth and that God showed
up killed all the other ones and then
took off into the Sun and just stayed
there and that was it
but but you have like all these entities
you know during that Civil War like the
early days of the gods
you had beings like Sid Iraq and the
octet and so like you know both I'm
sorry not both room
what's whom and those different guys
that like doctor strange calls on you
had those different entities who took
off to other dimensions and so that's
why like Sid Iraq has the Crimson Jim
that juggernaut uses but it's from the
crimson dimension and Doctor Strange has
the crimson bands of cyttorak which he
draws and selects power and all that
kind of good stuff but the whole idea
was that adversary was always trying to
like break into the Marvel Universe and
conquer the entirety of the universe
eventually it did and it was back at a
time when storm was in a relationship
with phenom sorry Forge had removed
storms powers and so she was you know
basically trying to get her powers back
but what ended up happening is basically
it took the entirety of like the x-men
and like a handful of other heroes and
and characters including Romo who's kind
of like this overseer of the multiverse
and what ended up happening is they they
basically they all I think they all
tried to fight against the adversary
they didn't win Forge cast a spell to
send the adversary back to his own
dimension
but he used the souls of the x-men to do
it that's what it was so we use the
souls of the x-men to send the adversary
back to his own dimension and then nine
of the x-men died and like it was it was
a huge like like storm and like the most
popular x-men were basically
quote-unquote dead Romo resurrected him
and gave him the siege perilous and what
this did is it basically meant that the
x-men you know according to what Romo
did made them invisible so they could be
superheroes not having to worry about
anybody tracking them down but the siege
perilous was a device that they could
use to reset their lives basically
meaning that they
could use a siege perilous and they
could start over nobody would know who
they were um I don't remember if it's
specified if they would keep their
powers but nobody would know who they
were like nobody who would remember them
or anything like that it would have this
huge cascading effect across the
universe but what ends up happening here
is in response to those x-men dying
Kitty Pryde and Nightcrawler are not
there they're actually recovering from
the mutant Massacre I'm pretty sure
that's right they're recovering from the
mutant Massacre when sinister sent
gambit and his Marauders to kill a whole
bunch of Morlocks in the tunnels of New
York and then gambit backed out of the
last minute when he realized what was
going on and so because of that Kitty
Pryde in in Nightcrawler I think end up
leaving the x-men they end up travelling
to Britain and they join with Captain
Britain to form the Excalibur team now
Excalibur was kind of cool I'm sorry
there's also Rachel summers okay if that
wasn't enough history and enough
information um man you better be ready
because I'm about to I'm about to make
your brain explode okay
uh Rachel summers Rachel summers is a
character who was cool for like one
moment and then Marvel didn't know what
to do with her anymore like they never
knew what to do with her character
there's one point where Rachel summers
has a Phoenix force and she defeats
Galactus or stalemates him or something
like that but like she goes toe to toe
with Galactus it's it's a pretty cool
thing nowadays we expect that because
it's the Phoenix you know it's a
multiversal entity but still at the time
Rachel Summers was the daughter of Jean
Grey and Scott Summers from the Days of
Future past now I'm sure a lot of you
guys have seen the Days of Future past
movie imagine that Kitty Pryde is the
daughter of Jean Grey and Scott Summers
and that Wolverines Kitty Pryde and
that's basically what happened the mind
of Kitty Pryde was sent into the past by
Rachel summers to stop Days of Future
past from happening Marvel didn't really
know how to handle alternate realities
back then all you really had in terms of
like alternate realities were like
Doctor Strange dimensions like Doctor
Strange would go to like the Dark
Dimension where Dormammu was he would go
to like the dream dimension where
Nightmare hung out out he would go to
like these different realities and
alternate universes or you know
dimensions and so on but that was the
extent of it
Marvel never really had a scenario where
somebody from the future would go into
the past and change things because then
the question became how do you reconcile
that and Marvel how to play it fast like
they had to figure it out quick so Days
of Future past happened
the mind of Katie pride goes into the
past and prevents the assassinations of
more McTaggart the mutant geneticist
Senator Robert Kelley and Charles Xavier
and that stops the Days of Future past
from happening the problem was that the
the issue bubble ran into was if Katie
pride went to the Past to stop Days of
Future past from happening then how
could she come from a future that
doesn't exist anymore and so what they
did is they simply said okay the Days of
Future past is now an alternate reality
that future still happens it's just a
different universe now it's not the main
Marvel Universe and so what they did is
they wrote a story called Days of Future
present and in days a future president
Rachel summers is yanked from her
reality into the main Marvel Universe
she basically tries to figure out why
hers didn't change she ends up in the
main Marvel Universe discovers Jean Grey
and Scott Summers are still alive
there's kind of a weird situation that
goes on there and then she just kind of
goes off and does her own thing and
she's free-floating for like the next
however many years she's been around and
that's it like I mean that's that's all
it she's does she's a character no one
ever knows what to do with no one
because I mean she was originally
designed to be a replacement for Jean
Grey but Jean Grey was back by that
point in time and so like x-factor was
going on and there was no one to figure
out what to like had a writer or
anything to do so they just threw her on
the Excalibur team and she just stayed
there for a little while following that
Excalibur was okay I mean you had things
like TechNet you had the Jim Jasper
storyline which was largely Captain
Britain I did that happen before
Excalibur but you had like a few things
that went on with their team the problem
with Excalibur and this is like to
something that might actually work for
the MCU the problem with Excalibur in
Marvel Comics is they seem so isolated
like it was like okay I sit down to read
Marvel Comics and in this specific
location in America I've got the
Avengers and I've got the x-men and I've
got x-force and I've got freedom force
and I've got starch some force works and
I've got like all these things going on
you know and I've got like the
Incredible Hulk and you kind of have
Alpha Flight but nobody really cares
about them well you've got all these
little things going on and then it's
like all the way over there is Excalibur
that's that's how it felt to the average
reader in terms of how the team
interacted and one of the things that
that fans really enjoy when it comes to
Marvel comics is having that shared
universe there's something to be said
about sitting down and reading like you
know x-man and The Incredible Hulk
annual number 98 and you see like x-man
Nate Dre and The Incredible Hulk
crossover with one another
that would never happen but you get to
see it x-man is basically the
Kable would be if cable was never
screwed up x-men it's like crazy
powerful it's he's like everything cable
could be um but still there's something
to be said about having that kind of
crossover that kind of interaction and
so for me as a reader I've never really
gotten to Excalibur from what I
understand from like the really hardcore
Captain Britain fans they love its
character and they love Excalibur but
it's one of those teams you never really
hear of you never really hear of like
you know it's caliber versus Avengers
one because why and two because it
really wouldn't be believable uh but
still it what it would do in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the reason why
this is a cool thing is because when you
look at the MCU it is very indicative of
like early 60s and 70s Marvel Comics
like the MCU is a homegrown American
thing and I think that like bringing in
stuff like excalibur bringing in things
like Alpha Flight bringing in things
like the Savage Land and like Avalon and
stuff like that would serve the purpose
of like bolstering out the entirety of
the community of the of the Marvel
Universe and expanding on what's already
there I mean on Netflix you have things
like the hand which is cool I mean you
basically get the super secret japanese
mystic ninja organization but they're
not part of the movies and because of
the fact that you know there's the whole
little you know pouting session going on
between like the TV side and the movie
side you'll probably never see the hand
crossover with the with them almost
automatic universe because I'll tell you
right now man like like the man tell you
right now I don't know I mean the hand
is okay and like in in on the Netflix
series let me tell you something man if
you had the hand from Marvel Comics
rolled over into the movies they would
give the Avengers or run for their money
I mean it would be insane like like I
would love to see that like a shadow
land thing if you don't know what that
is it's fine it's not a huge deal but I
would love to see you like a shadow land
MCU movie like like daredevil becomes
possessed by like the Beast of the of
the hand like the like the dark beast of
the hand and and it's just like I'm
leading the hand now and just like tries
to conquer everything that would be cool
like like that would be that'd be pretty
awesome but nonetheless I think it would
really help to kind of expand in and
build on the world of it
the thing about Excalibur is it kind of
has to be done right because if you do
it like they did in the comics people
won't really care that much you kind of
have to give people a reason to be
interested in them like you don't want
to have the Excalibur team in the MCU
and
they're just out there in the middle of
no man's land and you get a movie from
them once every ten years and then like
you may or may not see them reference
because people will forget about them
and people will you know people may or
may not find them interesting but again
I think that having like some European
representation in the MCU is a great
idea and I think it really needs to
happen I think Excalibur would be a
great way to make that work but anyway
guys all right let me know what you
think down in the comments section if
you don't know what Excalibur is I don't
remember if I have a video explaining
them or not I want to say I do I want to
say I do have a video explaining
Excalibur but I might not um but anyway
let me know down in the comments section
what you guys think and if you're new
here - comments explain make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]